Подорож в інший світ займає лише пів хвилини.
Тридцять метрів під землею: підземне містечко Гельсінкі.
Лабіринт із тунелів та підземних приміщень має захистити
дев'ятсот тисяч людей від ракетних ударів,
хімічної зброї та радіоактивного випромінювання.
На випадок війни… А ще?
Куку!
Ласкаво просимо на один з найулюбленіших ігрових майданчиків Гельсінкі для різного віку.
Хокейне поле та тренажерний зал, їдальня та автостоянка - як бонус.
Дехто навіть святкує тут свої дні народження.
Для нас це повсякденне життя. Ми виросли з цим бомбосховищем.
Для нас у цьому немає нічого незвичайного, ми навіть не замислюємося про це.
У всьому Гельсінкі повно таких підземних світів.
Цей бункер у центральному районі Гельсінкі - Хаканіємі -
один із найбільших у фінській столиці.
За словами представника цивільної оборони Томі Раска,
у приміщенні могли б розміститися два футбольні стадіони.
Однак у разі війни центр дозвілля у найкоротший термін
здатний перетворитися на повноцінне бомбосховище.
Звичайним сценарієм є використання притулку від кількох годин до кількох днів.
У більшості притулків ми можемо продовжити цей час.
Але тривале перебування тут буде пов'язане з усілякими труднощами.
Приміром, тепло, яке виділяє людське тіло.
Тільки один я безперервно виділяю близько ста ват тепла.
Проживання шести тисяч людей у такому закритому просторі - велика проблема.
Але не в Гельсінкі.
Місто стоїть на плиті з граніту та гнейсу.
Бункер розміщується в підземній скелі,
порода якої не тільки стійка, але й має охолоджувальний ефект.
До того ж, великі зали у разі потреби можна швидко переобладнати у безліч невеликих приміщень.
Таким чином тисячі людей можуть жити тут, під землею, впродовж тривалого часу.
Тут люди помиратимуть, народжуватимуться, хворітимуть,
тут будуть щасливі та сумні люди.
Просто життя нормального суспільства - лише всередині укриття.
Фінляндія має 1300 кілометрів спільного кордону з Росією.
Країна багато десятиліть відмовлялася від вступу в НАТО.
Аж поки не почалася повномасштабна війна в Україні.
Ось уже пів року, як Фінляндія стала членом НАТО.
Війна Росії в Україні змінила мешканців країни.
Більшість хоче більшого захисту, більшої безпеки.
Ми, фіни, схильні ставитися до всього цього стоїчно.
Ми знаємо, що цей ризик існував завжди,
відколи Фінляндія стала незалежною.
Він проявився під час Другої світової війни,
коли Радянський Союз намагався завоювати нашу країну.
І одного разу це може статися знову.
Ми знаємо про це, але не думаємо про це щодня і не боїмося цього.
Тепер на тлі нової війни в Європі події радянсько-фінської війни 1939-40 років
постають в іншому світлі.
Фіни тоді змогли відстояти свою незалежність.
Проте за це їм довелося заплатити високу ціну та поступитися частиною своєї території.
Московський мирний договір 1940-го року
став одним із підсумків цього похмурого розділу у відносинах між двома країнами.
Про ці події нагадує пам'ятник у центрі Гельсінкі.
Під час тієї, як її називають у Фінляндії, Зимової війни
було ухвалено перший закон про цивільну оборону.
Відтоді діє норма, що всі громадські споруди,
а також приватні будинки, починаючи з певних розмірів,
повинні мати свої укриття. І метро також.
Загалом лише у Гельсінкі налічується понад п'ять тисяч бомбосховищ,
розрахованих майже на мільйон людей.
Ми виконуємо свою роботу в надії, що нам це ніколи не знадобиться.
Але ми все одно повинні це робити.
Історія вчить нас, що якщо щось не виключено, то це може статися.
Жителі Гельсінкі хочуть бути готовими до цього,
і завжди мати можливість сховатися від небезпеки
на глибині 30 метрів під своїм містом.